هناك موضوع مثير الحقيقه الحديث فيه في
مختلف الدول الاوروبيه وهو موضوع الهجره
الهجره تمثل تحدي كبير خاصه في ايطاليا في
الحقيقه اصلا ما كان يعرف عن الايطاليين
انهم شعب مهاجر و يرحبون عامه بالاجانب
اولا هل تعتقد انه تغير هذا الانطباع
وتتغير هذا الانطباع عند الايطاليين ما
اسباب هذا التغيير
وانا متاكد من ان اراده الاستقبال مؤكده
من الحكومات المتعاقده لكن الفرق الذي
يميز والحكومه الحاليه اليوم هو التمييز
بين هجره شرعيه واخرى غير شرعيه خطا كبير
الخلط بينهم وهو خطا جسيم يحدث بحق من
ياتون الينا بشكل شرعي
ويندمجون في بلادنا فهي زي السين ليس في
شخص مهاجر او غير مهاجر
المشكل يكمن بين من يحترم المعايير
والاتفاقات والمعاهدات الدوليه والحدود
ومن لا يحترمها التمييز يجب ان نقوم به
على هذا الاساس والا فان الخطاب سيصبح
خطيرا نحن ندافع عن الاشخاص الذين ياتون
الى بلدنا بشكل شرعي
ونعتبرهم اضافه وثروه لايطاليا في مقابل
من يرغبون باختراق حدودنا وبالتالي عدم
احترامنا من خلال الدخول بالقوه
وبانتهاك بيتنا وبشكل غير شرعي